over the weekend 79 Chinese cities
triggered air pollution alerts as severe
winter smog covered large parts of the
country fighting pollution is just one
of the many items on the agenda at the
Climate Change Conference in Katowice
but for many countries the price of
confronting global warming is steep just
the fact that Poland is hosting this
gathering has been slammed by
environmental groups because of its
dependence on coal the Polish president
dismissed the critics was it karana
blast exhaust above not using one's own
natural resources in poland's case coal
and basing energy security on them does
not conflict with climate protection and
with progress on climate change the UN
begs to differ
it says greenhouse gas levels are again
at a record high worldwide if that trend
continues temperatures could rise by 3
to 5 degrees Celsius this century
extreme weather ranging from hurricanes
to droughts flooding and wildfires would
become the norm not an exception even as
we witness devastating climate impacts
causing havoc across the world we are
still not doing enough nor moving fast
enough to prevent irreversible and
catastrophic climate disruption the US
has said it is planning to withdraw from
the Paris climate Accord but many
American states and cities are deeply
committed to the pact they even brought
their big guns to Poland like former
California Governor Arnold
Schwarzenegger to try and show they'll
be back I wish
that it could be the Terminator
in real life